[Music]
hello and a very warm welcome indeed to
quadriga this week as German Chancellor
Angela Merkel visits China we take a
closer look at Beijing's geopolitical
ambitions President Xi Jinping has
established himself as China's leader
for life and he seems determined to
transform his country into the dominant
global power it's already challenging
the u.s. is the world's biggest economy
and now China is extending its strategic
and commercial influence through the
creation of a giant trading network
known as the New Silk Road so our
question on quadriga this week is the
New Silk Road China's route to Europe
and to discuss that question I'm joined
by three excellent analysts here in the
studio beginning with Bernhardt barche
who's a senior expert on China for the
birth of man foundation
he believes that time to balance China's
influence in a reasonable way may be
running out
also with mrs. Andrews Clute
editor-in-chief of handles blood global
he was once based in Hong Kong and has
for many years followed the rise of
China and threose says that Europe
should stop being naive China has a plan
for economic domination of the Eurasian
landmass and Singh's and a very warm
welcome to to Ruth Kirchner Ruth is a
freelance journalist and China expert
and she argues that China's belt and
Road initiative is a good idea in
principle but she goes on it lacks
transparency and ties participating
countries into an authoritarian system
thank you all three for being here with
me today I'd like to begin with you
Andres with that big statement at the
top of the show you say China has a plan
for the economic domination of the
Eurasian landmass and seas so how close
is Beijing to realizing that gold a
Beijing has a long time horizon which is
one of the things that distinguishes
China from the Western democracies and
it also looks far back and in in the
Chinese narrative China once was the
economic superpower of the world in in
our Middle Ages the Tang Dynasty and
onwards and then came the great
humiliation at the hands of the West
when the Western countries through the
Industrial Revolution passed
and left it behind Holton for the
Chinese psyche yes and they dwell on it
today the to an extent that is
surprising to us they're the opium wars
and whatnot but in their narrative it's
now all about re-establishing what is
rightfully theirs which is economic
power alongside other powers and I think
economic dominance eventually and to
translate that economic power into
political power and for that they have
unlike the West a a coherent plan that
has elements like the sub New Silk Road
like the targeted theft and transfer of
Technology and more mmm-hmm are we
already living in the the Chinese
century no I don't think we're already
living in that in the Tonys century what
I think what's happening well we're
witnessing is a shift of power centers
and away from the US but I don't think
this is a this is China centered yet and
but China is going to play a much more
dominant role in the future expansive
role and more expansive role definitely
economically and we see that through
grand schemes like the one belt one Road
initiative or the belt and road
initiative as it's now called in in in
in China but where where China wants to
move politically and strategically I
think that is a still a much more open
question we're not quite sure yet mm-hmm
and been about you say time to balance
China's influence in a reasonable way in
a reasonable way could be running out
what does that mean if you look at
what's happening in the u.s. we're
scapegoating China for taking America's
job away has become the dominant
political theme then that is quite a
dangerous populist path to take in
Europe we can be quite happy that we're
not there yet but of course China poses
a lot of challenges to the global
trading system to global governance and
there have to be a lot of negotiations
for what the global world order is going
to be and until we can still discuss
reasonably and we don't have populist
movements and we don't have pop
petitions who campaign on scapegoating
China for our problems there is still a
chance for good diplomacy to work things
out
mmm when you talk about scapegoating
China you've just said you you guys are
the birth of someone foundation you've
come up with a new report looking at
China buying up high-tech high-end
companies around Europe in Germany that
is viewed as a threat by many people in
Germany because they believe that the
Chinese it's the cliche isn't it they
believe that the Chinese are going to
copy reproduce and leave the Europeans
lying in the dust or is it more
complicated than that
it is more complicated than that because
China is now openly saying that they
want to become world leaders in core
technologies in the next couple of years
and what our report shows is that
they're very strategically buying German
and other European Western technology
companies and the problem there is that
our markets are very open they are
basically welcome to come and invest
here well their markets are closed and
closing even more so the problem is a
level playing and this this buy up that
you that you've been identifying and
writing about it say it takes place with
state backing so it makes for an unfair
playing field as it were absolutely
there's we don't know the ownership
structures there's there's state money
in there it's tied to this big plan made
in China 2025 we are all for for
competition that's what the German
economic model is built on but China is
very much unlevel in the playing field
and that kind of manipulation is a big
problem for the German industry yeah if
you just want to spell out that that
point about the unlevel playing field
the way in just in recent weeks what the
Chinese have been doing is they've
they've built a surreptitious
shareholding in Daimler a Chinese
company has bought up on without
acknowledging it at the proper time a
stake of about 10% and Daimler so that's
one of the technologies they're after
right now they're having a second
attempt to buy internal electricity grid
operator that is also quite strategic
and people and I think I like
what you said about in America it's gone
too far the populist Trump have taken
the debate here for some reason that
hasn't entered the populist sort of a
bullhorn yet and but there are I believe
in Germany for instance the people most
people are unaware of this but people
like Peter admire the New Economics
Minister it's now his job to think
calmly but firmly about this and because
for instance in the thing on his desk is
right now the Chinese are trying to buy
into the electricity a grid operator
again and and buy by our rules he could
I think intervene once they get 25
percent I believe and they stopped just
short of that at 20 percent and he has a
few weeks to decide he doesn't want them
to have it what does he do
so that's the dilemma we're in we have
rules and laws and we can't change those
quickly and they because they have
stayed back and they do whatever they
want okay the heart of our discussion
today is the New Silk Road project it's
a massive transport and trading
initiative that traces the ancient
trading routes of the old Silk Road
there are two main routes one is the
land route from China and across Central
Asia the Middle East and Russia into
Eastern Europe before reaching the
German city of Duisburg there's also a
maritime route that links southern China
and Southeast Asia with East Africa
before then also leading to Europe let's
find out a little bit more now about
what may well be the largest
infrastructure project in history
Chinese President G was joined by
representatives from more than a hundred
countries last year at the Silk Road
summit in Beijing among the participants
turkish President Erdogan and Russian
President Putin not in attendance German
Chancellor Merkel the New Silk Road
project intends to do much more than
revive the old trade routes with an
investment of nine hundred billion
dollars China wants to build an almost
global trade network with roads railways
ports and airports it would connect
China with Central Asia Africa and
Europe it's about business but also
about establishing influence and
political power in Germany and most
other European countries there's still a
feeling of mistrust the EU officials
won't currently sign a joint declaration
they say she doesn't adhere to European
values of transparency or environmental
and social standards China is advancing
west but who'll be using the new Silk
Road
[Applause]
Ruth Kirchner who will be using the new
Silk Road and is it a threat or an
opportunity well I think it's a bit of
both really it's an opportunity for a
lot of countries that desperately need
infrastructure investment both in Asia
in Central Asia but also in some parts
of Europe and of course in Africa that
all sounds very benign that is the idea
is such I think is benign and as I think
it's perfectly understandable to
actually in improve transport links and
connectivity across those regions I
think what we need to look at very
carefully is is individual projects and
who is benefiting who is financing these
projects who are the companies or where
the companies from mainly from China and
who are building these projects and
where does it leave the countries that
are involved in these projects does it
leave them with a higher debt levels as
we have seen in some countries and are
these are these projects really
beneficial to the countries that sign up
to it it almost does we're not just
trying to have a neo-colonial agenda it
almost sounds at times like the British
building trains in India they would
definitely say that they're not colonial
but when we look at it it definitely is
a geopolitical project it's not only
about trading and building
infrastructure the second step is of
course building political influence and
basically reshaping the world order
around the countries that join the the
new so you feel that it was right and
good for my for angular Merkel not to
have attended the the Silk Road summit
yes that the challenge here is that we
have to take up China's offer to say
that this is the multilateral and
project because this would be a good
idea in theory it's a good thing but in
practice until now it is not and the
challenge here is to work with China
because we need China as a partner we're
not going to contain China in any way we
shouldn't and at the same time we have
to acknowledge that China has a very
strong stir
oh gee there where we have none that we
don't have similar offers that we can
make to emerging economies telling them
we can help you to build power stations
and networks train networks in a similar
way so we have to be more receptive to
their needs and come up with an
alternative and only if we have an
alternative and it's actually in the
German coalition treaty that we need
European alternative to the Silk Road
only then can we put pressure on China
to level the playing field and make it a
truly multilateral a lot of these
projects can be both they they have a
strategic aim but they also have
economic benefits so if you build a
harbor for a country I mean that's good
for trade but you could actually also
use it for other purposes and military
for instance so I think part of that is
that is is is that we never quite sure
what we're talking about and of course
on the Chinese side it's also the lack
of transparency mm-hmm it's also Andres
it's also this is surely about values
were used to naively in the West assume
that if there's trade and there's
commerce and there are markets the
byproduct would be democracy that has
now proved to be rather naive to put it
mildly absolutely and in that whole
mixture of economics and political
policies I don't think the Chinese see
that distinction though that is a
Western liberal idea and I think it
mercantilist an economic nationalist
doesn't have that idea and I just want
to say that in the same places where
they're building the the road and as
well as the belt for instance that of
course overlaps with for instance the
South China Sea where they're
deliberately also trying to get America
in they have a strategy of extending
that perimeter where Chinese into which
they can project Chinese power and
prevent America American power from
being projected and then the South China
Sea they're simultaneously turning small
islets into permanent aircraft carriers
and they're happily picking off the
Philippines and other countries that
were in the American or the Western
orbit and and that that's difficult for
countries like New Zealand and Austria
in the long term and bringing them into
their orbit so they see this as one
project and that's why I call it
coherent and that is something that we
were not used to having they just like
to shift the focus a little bit because
we aren't ill we're talking about two
things here we're talking about China's
strategy but we're also talking about
angular Merkel's visit to Beijing which
is currently taking place it's her I
think it's her 11th visit to Beijing in
12 years in office yeah that's very
diligent yeah that's very committed how
is she seen in China is she an important
voice they think at the moment
China is quite willing to listen to
Germany and Europe because they need
Europe or they hope that Europe could
play a role to balance the US and then
they're very long-standing personal
connections at the same time China is
very realistic about what they can do
with with European countries and yes
they need Angela Merkel as the leader of
the strongest European country at the
same time they're doing a lot to drive
European countries apart mmm I'd be
interested for your take on that Ruth
because I you came I discovered a quote
from Angela Merkel saying that China
really only views Europe as a sort of
peripheral Asian Peninsula is it that
bad no I don't think it's that bad but I
think the Chancellor is very realistic
about the role Germany can or cannot
play and Germany is the biggest economy
in Europe is the most important country
within the EU but from the Chinese
perspective it's still a relatively
small country and so I think the
Chancellor is realistic about how much
weight she actually has she knows about
them and there's of course that
Germany's economic power and but when it
comes to the big geopolitical questions
and Germany's voice accounts a lot less
and I think that has to be taken into
account but we're suddenly discovering
out with that because we talked about
differences between Europe and China
there there are there's suddenly a lot
of common ground there is a comment
there there is a lot of common ground
and there isn't because a while where
when it comes to
both countries neither neither neither
China nor the nor Germany or the EU want
a tariff slept on some of their
exporting goods and they're also Germany
and the US have common interests visa
[ __ ] visa with China when it comes to
market access and when it comes to
economic policies in China and what
those both countries won't want to see
change so I think that puts actually
Chancellor Merkel in a in a pretty
difficult position maybe she wants on
the one hand to keep communication
channels with the u.s. open and she
minee needs the u.s. I mean China and
the US are Germany's biggest trading
partners but she also wants to wants to
carry on with a very good relations with
China but doesn't want to be seen to be
that she sort of being pushed into the
sort of China's arms because of the
conflicts but there were the Americans
you're nothing
absolutely okay I have two fears from
about this and one is first of all I do
think it's as bad as that quote suggests
from the Chinese point of view Europe is
a little appendage Peninsula at the end
of Asia and I think that Europe could
become in this century which is still
young rule takers not rule makers in the
second fear is that in that the Chinese
might clash with the reigning or waning
superpower which is America and I was
really intrigued when I was there this
is now years ago when I was speaking to
young scholars inside the Chinese
Communist Party and what they wanted to
talk about is the historical clash
between Britain and Germany in the 19th
century because that was the British
century and Germany rose to build its
empire its place in the Sun and it led
to eventually World War one which they
wanted to avoid the Chinese and I'd be
interested if they still are as keen to
avoid that permanently or if they just
want to avoid it until such a time as
when they think they could win such a
showdown with the US so I think it's
actually a dangerous world and I think
again this the 19th century was British
the 20th was American this one which is
just starting will be Chinese okay very
interesting thoughts indeed and rest
let's just go back a little bit to the
the New Silk Road and as we
have seen the Western German city of
Duisburg is an important hub on the
route Berta what does that mean in
concrete terms for this once prosperous
city that has more recently hit on
harder times Duisburg after 11,000
kilometers one trade route of the New
Silk Road ends here 25 trans a week
arrived with Goods and hope for the
future Chinese investors are very
welcome here we're building a China
Trade Centre here on this land behind us
we will have 120,000 square meters of
office space over 5 storeys 1000 Khatta
meetha that's appealing to a region with
high unemployment the coal industry lost
tens of thousands of jobs last year
Duisburg is also one of Europe's largest
inland ports an ideal hub to forward
goods on but how reliable is China as an
investor
[Music]
then I'd wash that's a good question how
reliable is China as an investor it
could be engaging in massive overstretch
here well if you look at it from a
German perspective then they are not
very big investors yet their strategic
investors if you look at the at the Silk
Road they they have a lot of money to
spend there but they can't buy the world
they will need other countries to
support the initiative and I think
that's that's the main main challenge
there it's not only about money and
actually we should not only look at the
money that China spends we are also
spending a lot of money the West is
spending a lot of money it's not like
China invented building bridges and
roads in developing countries maybe they
invented that 5,000 years ago but right
now they're doing what the World Bank
and a lot of other development agencies
have been doing it's interesting because
China in advance of Merkel's visits to
to Beijing as it has been complaining
itself and asking how reliable is
Germany as a trading partner China
points to and I'm quoting here a
protectionist trend in Germany saying
only 0.3% of foreign investors in the
German in Germany stem from China while
German firms have invested 80 billion
euros in China in recent decades the
charges economic exchange cannot be a
one-way street this has been the Chinese
ambassador to Germany speaking out much
quoted in advance of Angela Merkel's yes
in there they've got quite good at sort
of rhetorical red herrings and that you
know you you shaped the debate in admit
he was posing at the Davos as the
protector of Qi Jinping as protector of
free trade suddenly this is very cynical
that those billions of German investment
and the many other billions of American
and British and other investment in
China we could talk about that what
happens to that they are strict rules
that they're they have to form joint
ventures with local partners there are
stories from German Mittal stunt
companies of having these joint ventures
of having factories are the employees it
would look drill
tired so one day the German boss drives
home to see where they're going and
they're going to a identical Factory at
night working a second shift recreating
what they learned during the day so
these billions of in bet they have used
this in this investment into China - I
would say steal and transfer and copy
and then improve on key technologies and
so so there is so much wrong with that
that sort of allegation I don't even
know where to start and I think we
shouldn't fall for it
yeah and if you look at the openness of
of both markets the European market and
the Chinese market I mean it's very
clear that the U market is very very
open to foreign investment and a lot of
the investments that can that that are
happening here would not be possible
vice versa because the Chinese are
protecting their own industries and
don't have the same openness in their
investment rules and regulations and as
the European so I think the those those
quotes by the Chinese ambassador I mean
they were they were designed to sort of
steer the debate in a certain direction
I wouldn't agree with andreas but it's
very hard to take that seriously and how
much divide and rule is there in there
in the Chinese strategy we're certainly
seeing an element of that Chinese
attempt it would seem to drive a wedge
between Eastern European countries and
Western European countries and Brussels
I think there is a there is a certain
amount of sort of divide and rule and
but part of it is that the Europeans
allow this or let this happen and there
are very different interests and in
different parts of Europe there are some
countries that definitely want to
investment Chinese investment in their
infrastructure there are other countries
like Germany that do welcome Chinese
investment in of all sorts but have
become a bit more wary of it recently
and are now much kina on may be
screening Chinese investments a bit more
carefully so I think the the challenge
here for the Europeans is to come up
with a sort of joint strategy as over
his and so come up with a joint strategy
how to go about this challenge
to make it specific one of the big
discussions were having at the moment is
how are we going to monitor and control
investment in Europe and that is
something that by European law we have
to decide in Brussels and the issue
there is that China is very strongly
represented especially in Eastern
European countries so China is in fact
sitting at the table and has its allies
who are going to sabotage some of these
initiatives are you doing to name some
names there for us
well Hungary is the country that is very
much discussed at the moment there was
coming back to the Silk Road the famous
I should actually say report by European
ambassadors in Beijing who made a report
about how this new Silk Road is a very
China dominated and very manipulative
initiative and the Hungarian ambassador
was the only one who didn't sign that
report and didn't share in the concern
of his colleagues interesting okay we're
running out of time I just like to get
an answer to our core question today
under as is China coming to Europe in a
word yes of course they're already here
there it's going to be a Chinese century
we have to get used to it he's trying to
come into your they're already here
they're here to stay and so we have to
think carefully how to deal with them
they're here it's good that they're here
they're welcome that they're here we
can't out Chinese the Chinese but we
want to be there too and you want a
world with a level playing field thanks
very much for that and all your thoughts
today thank you to all three of you
being here on quadriga our topic has
been the New Silk Road China's routes to
Europe thank you for joining us bye-bye
and truce
[Music]
you